c'est toujours leur de babar issa avec
bravo loto le jeu 100% gratuit qui peut
changer ta vie
téléchargez l'appli jeter gris et tente
de remporter jusqu'à un million d'euros
sans rien faire bravo l'auto facile
d'être riche
[Musique]
pas super sexy mais voilà
le jour où un signe est venu manger dans
ma main c'est pas super sexy mais voilà
la grande copine destine ses meilleurs
souvenirs de vacances
c'était le camping du pavillon royal à
bidart avec des grands-parents et
j'étais inscrite au club mickey et à
chaque fois comme j'étais déjà très très
grande je gagnais toutes les épreuves et
j'avais des supers beau cadeau et les
super boulot des portes créer des
déguisements des tee-shirts donc ça
c'était absolument fabuleux donc ça
c'est mon meilleur souvenir jour j'ai
failli me noyer dans le lac léman et
donc la juive vraiment plein d'eau sur
la tête mais aussi dans les oreilles
dans les yeux et olemps sur la tête
j'aime pas mais dans les yeux dans la
boue dans les oreilles et d'un fondement
encore moi c'est encore avec ma maman
lendemain de tempête je me baigne et
tout d'un coup il ya des gros rouleaux
comme ça avec un énorme courant et je
vais me benoit il m'a vraiment
heureusement est une très bonne nageuse
elle vient vers moi et elle le sauve in
extremis elle plante ses ongles dont la
chair de mon dos j'ai des marques
d'ailleurs enfin plus maintenant mais à
l'époque j'étais en sang mais elle m'a
sauvée elle m'a sorti comme ça de la
noyade
[Musique]